all right we're back Wednesday Wednesday
hey lawn crews outside maybe one kind of
noise if you hear like this along mower
out there not hour-long no it's the
neighborhoods long crew yeah I'm like
the back stuff so what's on the list for
today you know what okay so all I've
been doing today I've been working on my
book you know faceless villain for which
you guys should know which is gonna be
like unsolved murders from 2000 to 2019
so I'm hoping to have that out by the
end of the year so I've been working on
that a little bit at a time that's right
guys I was writing about a [ __ ] I'm
writing about cases in 2001 and I was
reading about a case this morning that
was like an 18 year old girl she had her
an apartment and it was Super Bowl
Sunday 2001 January 28th which is also
my brother's birthday matter of fact she
was supposed to go over and hang out
with her mom and her sister and they
were gonna watch the game and stuff and
they kept calling her and calling her
and she wouldn't pick up I thought maybe
she would well maybe she's wanting to
watch the game with her friends or
whatever then her mom like was like okay
well where is she and then they went to
the house the next day and somebody just
[ __ ] stabbed her to death
damn how long's she been laying dead
there a day damn did and the police in
the 20 years since the crime has been
committed not one single suspect they
have no idea if it was somebody that
knew her or somebody it was the middle
of the day somebody just kept stabbed
her there was nothing stolen nothing if
they said it happened between noon and
three o'clock and she lived in like a
high-rise apartment building though it
was like other people and nobody saw a
goddamn thing must have been an
attempted rape well they see that's the
thing it's like the the police are not
disclosing whether she was raped or not
which sometimes they will do if they
have like a person of interest in mind
and there was like a particular thing
that was done and they want to keep that
from the public so that's something like
that yeah so so that they can like you
know winnow out people that do false
confessions stuff but I was just like I
just [ __ ] just somebody wanders in
the DNI's apartment in the [ __ ]
middle which is she had a dog and
everything yeah people do that it's
crazy crazy crazy case but yeah it's
crazy but you know yeah it's not unusual
they're doing that they still don't get
in all those cases that we talked
about yeah sometimes it's just random
[ __ ] just walks in yeah and they
still don't know if it was somebody that
newer just some stranger that happened
to be wandering around or somebody that
stalked her like cuz she worked at the
mall or whatever but I don't know it was
like really it was somebody who knew
where she was
yeah and totally random yeah it's
usually not it's and usually like
something in the middle of the day like
that seems really weird even BTK he'd be
watching him he knew where they were
yeah well and the thing too it's like I
finished reading that book about BTK and
I'm still putting up the quotes every
Wednesday if you guys saw that on
Instagram today but um he said that even
though like he's like yes serial killers
you know how did why do they stop and
stuff he's like I never stopped I just
didn't do any murders in that time he
was stalking people that whole time he
had projects going that's what he called
them PJs projects and I never pulled the
trigger and he named him and everything
like you have project whatever like the
street name or you know look at whatever
kind of car she had or something like
that and he would stalk them sometimes
for like weeks and stuff and he would
like fantasize about how he's gonna get
in and he would and then he would just
never get around to it for whatever
reason um but he said he never stopped
like stop sounds like he was addicted
more than to the fantasy than that then
actually he seemed like a very fantasy
pro person I mean because some of the
[ __ ] that he says in that book I mean he
must have had like a really active
finish and it wasn't all about like
murders and stuff either like sometimes
he would just have these entire fans
like he would just see this random woman
and he would build an entire fantasy
about him like meeting her and then like
he was going to like meet her family and
they were going to upstate New York and
they were gonna have Christmas there and
he would you know when he would like
decorate the whole house and I was I'm
like damn that's batshit insane and I'm
a writer I have to imagine stuff all the
time but it's like I don't I don't do it
- that [ __ ] crazy has some kind of
escape pistou personality where he
didn't he didn't what he was doing in
real life wasn't good enough he had to
have alternate lives yeah it definitely
did seem like that way he would have
more lives yeah more stuff going on than
other people yeah yeah yeah he
definitely um I'm imagine he had like
whole world's going on here [ __ ] head
it's just like some of the [ __ ] that he
says it's just like and he's master of
all those world
oh yeah yeah oh yeah that was like a big
part of it yeah but yeah so Oh another
thing too that had some speaking of
writers this is really weird that I
didn't know this because I'm kind of
like into horror and I'm into Stephen
King and everything I didn't know that
on Stephen King's website he has a
program thing called dollar babies and
you can buy if you're a student
filmmaker you can buy the rights to one
of his short stories that he has listed
there for a dollar and you can make a
short film out of it huh as long as you
don't like you know obviously this is
you know it's gonna like make a [ __ ]
you know thirty million dollar movie you
can try that but he's saying as long as
it's like a student film and it's like
you're not like making profit off or
anything its first film students yeah
like a fan like a fan film yes so you
can actually just buy the rights for
Dell you have to you have a contract and
everything like that you can do that and
they have like a he has like a big list
of stories a lot of them are from
nightshift
and something like the older stories
like because I recognized a whole bunch
of them like the man he would not shake
hands and the woman in the room and last
rung on the ladder which I really like
that story it's not really a horror
story per se I guess it's kind of more
of a suspense or drama but I always
really liked it but yeah so I thought
that was kind of cool it's just I don't
know why I never knew that but I just I
was watching I think I was watching the
guys on bloodbath and beyond
earlier like I was watching a movie or
review of theirs and they mentioned it
offhand like as they were talking about
some movie that said struck them as very
Stephen King like and they said oh I
wonder if this was one of those dollar
babies and I'm like what was that I had
to go plug it up and then I was like
super I'm like well [ __ ] man now I wish
I knew how to make movies so I could
make like although to be honest if I
wanted to make a movie I could just make
one out of my own story or you can make
one out of a story that was in the
public domain cuz there's a lot of good
ones you got too many of your own
they're good enough you think I think so
that one zombie one I liked the zombie
cannibals I think that would make it
good that's actually gonna be on the
witching hour show tomorrow okay I'm
it all right yeah so that'd be a good
one I like that one
yeah but uh so there you got a little
little preview there people like zombie
stories that's what's going I think
that's what's going up tomorrow pretty
sure I got to keep I gonna calendar over
there where I try to keep track of
everything but I still forget because so
many things keep up with what else uh
what have you got going on - nothing
boring it's a boring it's a boring
boring boring you woke up early you went
for a walk with me this morning he
hardly ever does that yeah
cuz usually I get up and go and get back
and make coffee and clean the kitchen up
before you but boring and sleepy now
this week for the for the main show
we're doing the strongmen no what are we
doing we can do it the week after that
okay what are we doing this one coming
up Atlanta child murders okay all right
which is probably a good time to do this
one because I think HBO just has like it
has that's one case okay it's one case I
know it's when you're talking about the
the DJ guy yeah they did it on mine huh
what's his name again
Williams Wayne Williams Wayne Williams
yeah and like I said HBO is just I mean
somebody just requested it and then I
found out that HBO had done like like a
docu-series about it that they had just
put up that's streaming so I figured it
was a good time to do that one
I was surprised we hadn't done that one
yet oh and then I'm sitting there did we
do it and I'm like maybe I'm just
thinking about because we saw it on mine
Hunter yeah I guess that's why I thought
I thought we we haven't gotten around to
it because there was so many other other
requests well that's what I mean it's
like I have some spin to the point to
where man the true crime shit's getting
oppressive man we need to get back to it
we just we just did a ParaNorman oh I
mean I was gonna do a true-crime one and
then if you wanna do the strongman week
there's some new emotion I want that I
wouldn't even mind talking about Bob
Lazar getting down to the bottom of that
[ __ ] he's on the list somewhere - why
can't I can put him like I like I said I
like the kind of story about Bob yeah I
like to kind of do true crime and then
do something else but I that doesn't
always work out because we have so many
true crime requests but when I start
doing that we can do that okay
we have to start thinking of something
to do for the 200th stro - because we
only have like five weeks six weeks left
what are we gonna do we already do like
super long shows without meaning to
so it's not like we can get you ho like
super long chef baby like big deal it's
the same as usual
why should some that global conspiracy
dang about New World Order in the
Illuminati and all that maybe that's
been on the list for a long time long
time reptilians please that guy's name
again
David a key idea however I don't know I
ain't pronounce it look like I think
it's David Icke II I think I've heard it
pronounced like six different ways at
least it's [ __ ] gay and I can't listen
to him long enough to like it a name so
actually there's actually reptiles yeah
it's true got that from V that's see
that's what I thought yeah that's what
he just saw that once and forgot that he
saw it and then he thought he's going
you thought of that doggy thought of
that he thought he thought of it yeah
and that it was real he thought that was
[ __ ] was a documentary
it's true though I'm a reptilian yeah if
I knew how to do special effects I would
make like scale he remembers now because
everybody would blow it would blow
everyone's mind he remembers it cuz that
was back in the 80s and they had this
hot blonde chick and there's this one
[ __ ] scene where she's in that red
leather alien outfit she pulls her jaw
out swallows a big mouse I remember
that's not very that's a very famous
scene I remember that one too and I
don't even watch that show with any
regular members that that so became rep
to you there on out yes see no that's
what as soon as I knew about that guy I
don't even remember how I first heard
about that guy but I was like really
somebody actually believes that okay but
um but that was the first thing I
thought when I thought I'd it's like did
he think he was a documentary it's not
that it's not that different from they
live - yes I'm alert concert yeah that's
also very similar although they I guess
I don't know yeah I guess it's pretty
similar they're not cuz if it wasn't
they live aren't really
reptilian they're just kind of they look
like then how many skin they were aliens
yeah I know they look like people turned
inside out right I always liked the
makeup in that though
yeah it's cheesy its cheesy but I like
it it's
supposed to be in 1950s look and it was
yeah woman that's what I mean they were
they were going for that aesthetic right
because you know John Carpenter was like
really into like 50s monsters yes like
fifties Flying Saucer
yeah it looks like well they did the
same thing with Mars Attacks except with
much more self-awareness or I guess
would be the word for it but yeah so so
you didn't there's nothing else you want
to talk I'm sleepy
already it's only what we're recording
this at 325 and I will well I woke up at
I woke up before you did I woke up at
quarter to 6:00 um cat we can't waking
me up what was her problem I don't miss
you run out of treats or yeah it's part
of it oh forget beating down the damn
shades yes it's right next to my head
yeah I go what then she [ __ ] runs and
runs away what she runs and yeah jenny
is like check her bowl maybe she hasn't
any food looked over because I keep a
little plate near the bed on the other
side of the nightstand and I looked on
the other side of the nightstand their
plate was empty
so I gave her some cash yeah gave her
some Kitty crack because she's so amped
ations they come yet a square box honey
knows man she look everybody knows that
that's Kitty correct they can't stand it
well that's why that's that's why that
commercial like cracked me up were they
like are getting that's and I've only
seen it a couple of times but they like
he's throwing the the temptations like
off the second-floor balcony and the
cats like flying up there to get him and
stuff and I'm like yeah they do that
accurate illegals in that [ __ ] I've got
well I've gotten other kinds of treats
like I got some of those ones at Aldi
and like I got some news what I ordered
some from chewy that were like a
different brand and stuff nope they'll
eat them but it's they're just kind of
like not with not much enthusiasm after
about ten of them they're like me hey
there's just something for some reason
the temptations we get like this big
ones that are like eight bucks or
whatever and that's like you shake that
[ __ ] and they're like that what where
where yeah they don't like don't like
junkies and they don't care about what
flavor they are there
they're all really so they've got some
kind of an ingredient in there that cats
just [ __ ] can't stand it they just
tear it up I don't know what it is I
don't know I got a look in the back it's
probably some secret ingredient that's
what I'm saying it's probably just like
some kind of corporate prize like they
don't wanna do well they don't want all
their competitors knowing what the
surprise some kind of chemical that has
a certain smell that makes them want to
eat it because they don't have much of a
taste buds yeah but they have a really
good sense of smell
I don't know that don't know it but cats
have a better sense of smell the dogs
Jackson galaxy told me that so there
must be something that's really stinky
to them yeah not to us
maybe something smells like dirty feet
yeah because they well houki for real
she loves feet yeah clean dirty she does
if it doesn't stink she doesn't like it
yeah she's super interesting try to keep
tried you know she'll only eat fish
flavored canned food yeah or turkey with
cheese gotta have that cheese she got a
cheese in it it's gotta be musty and
if it's any other flake flavor like
she'll like beef or something she'll
kind of eat it reluctantly she'll kind
of lick it and then she'll be like port
I poured a little pile of Parmesan
cheese down and plate one time she ate
that yeah yeah cuz it stinks yeah they
like things but I was gonna say I mean
Pookie doesn't she usually knows better
than I mean if it's still dark in the
room she usually knows better than to
like make a whole bunch of noise I mean
sometimes she'll jump up on your chest
like cuz she wants to snuggle or
whatever but it's like if she starts
banging on that [ __ ] shade yeah that
in and it's dark in the room that
usually means she's out of food and
she's not happy about it we're talking
about a cat we gotta go people hear that
yeah they do
everybody loves Pookie alright so uh
have a good rest here Wednesday and
we'll talk to you guys like share
subscribe yeah